let's see if we can get the molecular
structure for butyl butyl cyclo
cyclopentane so you would just break
this up the way we've done it in the
last several videos it is a the suffix
is Ain so it is an alkane all single
bonds so single single bonds
it's pentane so we're dealing with five
carbons on kind of the base or on the
kind of the backbone so this is five
carbons and it's a cyclopentane so it's
five carbons in a ring so it's five
carbon ring is the backbone and then we
have a butyl group added to that five
carbon ring now you might say hey Sal
how do I know which carbon to add it to
when you're dealing with a ring and you
only have one group on the ring it
doesn't matter because let me just show
you what I mean so let's draw the five
carbon ring let's draw the cyclopentane
so it'll just be a Pentagon so one two
three four five and then you it's a ring
so you can connect them one two three
four five now it doesn't matter where I
draw the butyl group it's all symmetric
around there we just have a ring and
it's connected to a butte a butyl group
at some point it'll start to matter once
we add more than one group so we can
just pick any of these carbons to add
the butyl group to now just as a review
the butte prefix that refers to remember
methyl ethyl propyl or meth f probe
butte this is four carbons this is a
four four carbon alkyl group so let me
just add it here I could have added it
to any of these carbons around this
cyclopentane ring so if I just add it
right here so I'm going to have four
carbons so one two three four that is
the butyl part of this whole thing and
then let me just attach them up so you
might be tempted to just draw this right
there and actually this would be right
this is butyl cyclopentane but a
question might rise I just happened to
connect the cyclopentane to the butyl at
this first carbon on the butyl right
there I could have just as easily done
it like this I could have just as easily
had a I could have just as easily had it
like this where let me draw my butyl
again so I have one two three four so
once again this is a butyl but instead
of instead of being bonded to the
cyclopentane on my first carbon maybe
it's bonded right here maybe let me do
it with that yellow color maybe it's
bonded right here why this seems like
maybe this could also be butyl cyclo
pentene it looks like we have a butyl
group
this is butyl right here I drew a butyl
group right over here and I also draw a
butyl group right over here but these
are fundamentally two different
molecular structures I'm touching the
first carbon here I'm touching the
second carbon over here now there's two
ways to differentiate this one is the
common naming and one is the systematic
naming so let me differentiate between
the two so in the common naming and this
can get a little bit involved and this
frankly is probably the most complicated
or a part of naming organic compounds
systematic is often more complicated but
it's easier to I guess systematically
come up with it so there's a common and
then there's a systematic systematic
systematic so the common way of doing it
is if you just if you just say butyl
cyclopentane that implies that you are
bonding to the first or depending on you
the last carbon in the chain so this
right here is butyl cyclopentane this
right here is not just butyl
cyclopentane what you would do is you
definitely have a cyclopentane ring so
this would definitely be a cyclopentane
cyclohexane cyclopentane and you do have
a butyl group on it so we do have a
butyl group a butyl group but because we
are bonded we aren't bonded to the first
carbon we're bonded to a carbon that is
bonded to two other carbons we call this
sec-butyl cyclopentane
SEC let me so this is SEC and everything
I'm doing is obviously freehand if you
were to see this in the book the SEC
would be italicized or sometimes it
would be written as s as s butyl s butyl
butyl cyclopentane cyclohexane that is
touching two other carbons so you look
at the butyl group and say well which of
these carbons attached to two others
it's either that one or that one and
regardless of whether you're attached to
this or this you think about it it's
fundamentally the same molecular
structure so that's what you do when
you're attached to that guy right over
there but what about the situation we're
dealing with just the common names right
here what about the situation where it
looks like this so we have our
cyclopentane right there and we have a I
guess we could call it a butyl group
it'll have four carbons in it but let's
say that the four carbons look something
like this let's say our four carbons so
we have one two three four one two three
four carbons and we're bonded to this
one right over here so whenever you're
bonded to I guess one end of the four
carbon group and it branches off at the
other end and it seems a little
complicated this only deals four alkyl
groups below really five or six carbons
this we call an isobutyl group so let me
write this down so this is this right
here is SEC beetle or s butyl sometimes
for short this right here this right
there is isobutyl I so it's actually I
so that is an isobutyl group and then
the last thing to worry about when
you're dealing with butyl groups is
something like this is something like
this so let me draw it so you could also
draw four carbons like this you have one
carbon one two three four one two three
four carbons and you're attached over
here now this naming this group this
group right here you're going to see the
systematic naming is
much easier for these compounds this
group right here over here that the
carbon you're attached to is attached to
two other carbons so it is sec-butyl
when you're attached to three
it is t-butyl or tert-butyl so this
right here is a tert tert tert-butyl
group or sometimes called a t-butyl and
i really want you to understand the
difference here the common naming it's
easier to say and easier to spell but
it's sometimes a little confusing this
is just straight-up butyl so you would
call this butyl cyclopentane this is sec
butyl because you have this guy's
connected to two carbons that's where
the sec comes from that's where the sec
comes from sometimes it'll be s butyl so
this could be called sec-butyl sec-butyl
cyclopentane or s butyl cyclopentane
this because we're attached to the end
way from this branching off is still a
butyl group since we have four carbons
but since we're attached here this is
isobutyl so this is isobutyl
cyclopentane and then finally since the
carbon we're attaching to is attached to
one to three other carbons it is
it is a tert-butyl or a t-butyl group so
this is T butyl cyclopentane that's the
common naming so maybe I should clear
out systematic here just so it's clear
to you just so it's clear to you that
everything we've done here is common
naming is common naming so let me write
down it won't hurt to write them down
again because I'm more familiar with you
are with these the better so this is
just butyl butyl butyl cyclo pentene
this is s or sec butyl sec-butyl
cyclopentane and this is iso isobutyl
butyl cyclopentane cyclopentane we're
going off the screen here and then
finally this is tert-butyl or t-butyl
cyclopentane now i said these are the
common naming what are the systematic
naming well in the systematic this is
still butyl
little pentane so let me write this down
systematic systematic this is still
butyl cyclopentane which makes sense
this is this is very clearly a set of
cyclopentane this is very clearly a
butyl group but the systematic naming
what we try to do is we try to name we
try to name this group right here just
as we would name a traditional chain but
we ended with an ill so if you look at
this right here
what we do is we just consider the chain
where we attach so if you look at we
attached over here so the longest chain
that it from that point is there and
there so if you look at it like that it
looks like you have one two three
carbons and you have one carbon attached
on the beginning so this little group
right here in the systematic naming this
looks like a 1 2 3 3 carbons that's the
probe prefix so we're dealing with a
probe and it's all going to be one group
so it's a propyl group this is a propyl
group but it has a methyl remember meth
is one carbon it has a methyl group
attached on the first carbon so this is
one one methyl one methyl propyl now
that describes just the group that
describes one methyl propyl describes
just this part right here that describes
just that right over there and then to
have the whole compound to describe the
whole compound you'd put this in
parenthesis so this is the systematic
naming so one methyl 1/2 put an L there
we've been in the same color one methyl
because you have the your starting where
you're attaching so one methyl you have
a methyl group right there on that first
car but it's appropriate change one two
three propyl and then you would say
cyclopentane cyclone
that's the systematic name for that now
if you look at this one right here what
in the common name is isobutyl what you
do is you look at where we attach where
we attach is one two three carbons
so once again I'm doing that same one
two three carbons so once again this is
a propyl probe is four three but with a
methyl group now is attached to the one
to the second carbon so this is two
methyl let me make some space here this
is two methyl so that describes this
group right here that describes this
entire group cyclopentane cyclopentane
remember this is a systematic name you
might sometimes see this referred to as
isobutyl cyclopentane or two methyl
propyl cyclopentane this is actually why
l spelled it wrong and then finally do
the same exact idea here but it becomes
a little bit more interesting over here
we are attached to this carbon and the
longest chain I can do starting with
that carbon it's just one is just one
chain right there so we just have a two
carbon chain right one two the prefix
for two carbon is F ill or F F then
since it's a group at fill and then we
have two methyl groups we have two we
have two methyl groups attached right
over there and it's attached on the one
carbon right this is one and this is two
we call the one carbon where we are
attached to the broader chain so this is
going to be you would actually write one
comma one to show that we have two
groups attached to the first carbon and
both of them are methyl and so we write
one one dimethyl die for to die methyl
so this entire group right here which we
also called t-butyl when systematic
naming is one one we have two groups
attached to this first carbon one one
dimethyl ethyl
that's this whole thing this is the
ethyl and then we have two methyls
attached there that's why you write one
one they're both attached to the one we
have two of them that's why we wrote
died over there so it's one one dimethyl
ethyl and then finally cyclopentane
cyclopentane so hopefully that doesn't
confuse you too much I think if you
watch the video over and over and try to
practice it with your own problems
the systematic name way is actually
pretty pretty logical and actually if
you have more than five or six carbons
in the group they always or they tend to
always use the systematic naming